all right there's one thing that
Democrats are arguably better at than
Republicans and that's the kind of the
nuts and bolts of all the campaign stuff
like getting their voters registered and
then making sure they actually vote
either in person or VIA mail and ballot
now we all know a lot of Republicans
prefer voting on Election Day I'm one of
them uh but political operatives have
been warning party officials for years
that they either step up their early
voting efforts or prepare to keep losing
in 2022 according to the US elections
project Democrats accounted for
42.5% of early ballots but Republicans
only accounted for
33.8% so it's pretty obvious that it's
smarter politics to log as many votes as
you can as early as possible early
engagement matters that's exactly what
Virginia governor Glenn yunan is trying
to do with his secure the vote effort
before early voting ends on Saturday
every seat in the Virginia house which
is currently controlled by rep
Republicans and the state senate
controlled by the Democrats is now up
for grabs that's 140 seats on the line
on Tuesday so if Republicans can get
voters energized get them out to the
polls this could mean a GOP Trifecta
joining me now from the latest stop on
his secure your vote bus tour got a
rowdy crowd there Governor great to see
you what's at stake with this early
voting and getting this election
going well we have our entire house our
entire Senate up I think they're the
most important elections in the nation
because I think what's at stake is the
the entire future of the platform we are
demonstrated that you can reduce taxes
you can back the blue you can support
parents and put them at the head of the
table you can raise expectations in
schools and we've created 230,000 jobs
in 22 months that puts us near the top
of the nation and that's what's on the
ballot and of course the other side all
they have to sell is fear and we're
talking about hope for the future and
hope beats fear every day of the week
and that's what's on the ballot and
that's why the early voting has been so
important we've seen an uplift in early
voting that has been great across the
Commonwealth and most importantly Lura
in our Battleground States we've really
seen a move and I think this is going to
make a big difference when these
elections are finally tallied now the
Democrats uh everyone you know has in
the D DMV area DC Maryland Virginia
they've been pummeled with these
abortion ads because that they think
that's gonna get women and young people
out to the polls and you
say well of course that's all they have
to talk about is fear and of course
they're standing for extreme abortion
policies just three years ago they
wanted to in fact enable abortion all
the way up through and including birth
uh with no exceptions and we all
remember the former Governor saying that
we would keep a child comfortable while
we decide whether child lives or dies
we've been talking about a bill to
protect life at 15 weeks with with
exceptions where a baby can feel pain
and I believe that this is going to be a
decision between No Limits and
reasonable limits and it's one that I
think we will win nearly 70% of Virginia
support our position and that that
enables us to then start talking to
voters about these most important issues
around jobs and schools and parents and
crime and building a much better
Behavioral Health System and delivering
for virgins and as I said earlier the
other side has no agenda whatsoever
other than self fear and we are the
party of Hope in the future and they're
the party of fear um polling of likely
voters Governor is showing a dead heat
for control of the general assembly
right now Democrats barely edging out
Republicans by 1 Point 42 to 41 uh why
is it so close given how bad inflation
still is uh the uh illegal immigrant
situation in Northern Virginia I mean
even my Democrat friends are like this
is out of control um obviously that's a
federal issue but still it's tagged with
the to the Democrats and and just the
general sense of pessimism about schools
and and where Democrats lead kids off
the cliff as far as these social issues
go well remember where we're coming from
Lord 24 months ago Virginia was
completely controlled by democrats and
then of course we we had the big
statement in 2021 where all Virginians
came together and we swept the Statewide
races and we were able to flip our house
the Senate wasn't up and now we have to
finish the job we did have redistricting
and the districts have been drawn very
fairly and so this is a tossup and this
is why we are battling so hard down the
stretch to hold the house and flip the
Senate I think our record has been
incredibly strong we have great
candidates I'm here in henrio County
where where Senator Siobhan dunan is
trying to rewin and be reelected and of
course we have great candidates for
delegate and and and and Riley Shai and
David Owen we've got to get these folks
elected and when we do this we hold our
house and flip our Senate but that is
what's on the ballot and this is so
close down the stretch that's why I've
been encouraging Republicans get off the
sideline go make a plan to vote early we
have early voting all the way through
Saturday of this week and then of course
the final election is on Tuesday and we
got to get everybody out we turn out
Republicans vote Republicans win and
that's what we're about to do in
Virginia but this is going to be tight
down the stretch and we need everybody
to turn out and vote well I hope this is
a message to Republicans Nationwide
everyone's going to be watching what
happens in the results on Tuesday on
this offe election Governor but
nationally Republicans have got to get
on board get voting early and Bank those
votes because man we know the Democrats
do it Governor we'll be watching this
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else